[Musique]
vous allez où vous venez d'être vacciné
contre la commune de 6,9 voici ce que
vous devez savoir d'abord vous n'êtes
pas immédiatement protéger dans les
essais sur le vaccin de father my own
tech par exemple les cas d'infection ont
commencé à ralentir à partir de la
douzième journée après la première dose
alors qu'ils ont continué d'augmenter
dans le groupe qui recevait un placebo
la réponse immunitaire est donc déjà
bien présente
après la première dose mais la dose de
rappel est nécessaire pour une
protection plus forte et plus durable
dans certains endroits dont le québec on
a décidé de reporter la deuxième dose au
delà des trois ou quatre semaines
prévues pour vacciner le plus de gens
possible mais on ne sait pas encore quel
impact cela aura sur la protection
après les vaccinations attendez vous à
des effets secondaires qui ressemblent à
ceux de n'importe quel autre vaccin pour
y avons mal aux bras longs muscles à la
tête être fatigué ça devrait passer en
un jour ou deux attention ces effets le
sont plus fréquents après la deuxième
dose qu'après la première c'est normal
c'est là que votre système immunitaire
réagit le plus fortement au début des
campagnes d'immunisation on a vu des cas
d'allergies sévères au vaccin des
données publiées la semaine dernière et
qui porte sur plus de 17 millions de
vaccinations aux etats-unis montrent
qu'elles sont finalement assez rares
un peu moins de cinq coques par millions
de doses administrées pour le vaccin de
pfizer deux cas et demi par millions de
doses pour celui de modern a surtout
chez des gens qui avaient déjà eu des
réactions allergiques sévères
aucun décès n'a été attribué au vaccin
une fois vacciner est-ce que vous pouvez
enlever votre masque et augmentez vos
contacts n'ont pour le moment trop peu
de gens sont vaccinés et la transmission
est encore trop importante dans la
population les mesures sanitaires sont
donc encore là pour eux en plus on n'a
pas encore assez de données pour être
certain que les vaccins peuvent prévenir
l'infection
on sait qui protège très bien contre la
maladie y compris ses formes sévères
mais ça n'empêche pas en théorie qu'on
puisse être infectées et ensuite
potentiellement transmettre la maladie à
quelqu'un d'autre
certaines juridictions quand même
commencé à changer les règles
aux etats-unis par exemple depuis la
semaine dernière les gens qui ont
complété leur vaccination ne sont plus
obligés de s'isoler s'ils ont été en
contact avec quelqu'un qui avait la
commune 19
en israël les voyageurs vaccinés sont
maintenant exemptés de l'obligation de
faire une quarantaine à l'arrivée pour
le moment ce type de mesures n'est pas
en vigueur au canada